[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
25 novembre 1867 alfred nobel
le père des prix nobel fait breveter
d'inventions qui révolutionnera les
grands ouvrages
[Musique]
éventré une montagne creuser une galerie
ouvrir un passage tout cela devient
possible grâce à la dynamite
c'était il ya cent cinquante ans
durant des siècles la poudre à canon
reste le seul explosif
pour mener des guerres et effectuer de
grands travaux or la découverte de la
nitroglycérine
l'ingrédient à la base de la dynamite
changera le cours de l'histoire
instable et liquides la nitroglycérine
est cependant très dangereuse
ultra sensible aux chocs la manipuler
c'est risqué s'agit d'ailleurs elle sera
rapidement interdite en europe
[Musique]
alfred nobel
un chimiste suédois devient le premier à
maîtriser la puissance de la
nitroglycérine en lui ajoutant 25% de
ces dites une poudre d'albi fossilisés
le mélange devient pas te il peut ainsi
une moulée sous forme de bâton qu'il
enveloppe ensuite de papier on estime
que la dynamite est alors de trois à
cinq fois plus puissante que la poudre à
canon pour rendre la dynamite encore
plus sécuritaires nobel invente un
mécanisme capable d'amorcer la
détonation de la nitroglycérine à
distance
[Musique]
en contrôlant la mise à feu n'est pas
important est franchie vers la maîtrise
des explosifs
[Musique]
depuis la recette de la dynamite a
changé afin de la rendre encore plus
stable et plus puissante
encore utilisé de nos jours elle a tout
de même été progressivement remplacés
par les explosifs moderne
[Musique]
le lien entre la dynamite et le prix
nobel s'établit en 1888
lorsque le frère d'alfred décède un
journal de l'époque commet une erreur il
imprime plutôt la nécrologie d'alfred
qu'on qualifie alors de marchands de la
mort trouble et alfred nobel veut
changer cette image
il décide donc de léguer la majorité de
sa fortune pour la création d'un prix
grâce aux intérêts générés par sa
fortune sa fondation récompense
financièrement l'excellence dans cinq
domaines la paix la littérature la
médecine la chimie et la physique
chaque année depuis 1901 le mois
d'octobre amorce la saison des nobel
l'homme aux 355 brevets croyais
naïvement que sa découverte allait
mettre fin aux guerres
son voeu ne se réalisera jamais mais il
accéléra l'essor des grands travaux
en plus de souligner chaque année des
fluides l'intelligence humaine